bonjour à tous je suis ben de l'émission
nota bene et aujourd'hui j'ai envie de
vous présenter le premier épisode d'une
série de programmes dédiés à la
propagande que j'ai réalisé avec l'ina
l'institut national de l'audiovisuel
allez c'est parti pour un épisode sur la
propagande durant la seconde guerre
mondiale
[Musique]
il arrive à un jour du moins doux dans
ce pari fiévreux à peine sorti des
barricades tout s'arrêtait de compter
ses morts
pour lui crier sa ferveur il rapportait
cette victoire qu'on avait un peu perdu
et dont le premier ou 18 juin 40 il
n'avait pas désespérée et puis à ce
peuple meurtri que l'ennemi pendant
quatre ans avait humilié pour mieux la
servir
il rapportait cette chose immense et
merveilleuse la liberté
lendemain de la guerre tout est à
reconstruire les vies et les familles
les murs et les toits les routes et les
ponts mais il faut surtout reconstruire
la france une certaine idée de la france
[Musique]
une page blanche est ouverte sur
laquelle un récit reste à écrire et
comme souvent les mots de ce récit
seront ceux du pouvoir
il faut alors commencé par dire que la
france de pétain n'a jamais été la
france le gouvernement de bordeaux avait
choisi la capitulation la continuation
de la ligue 1 nouvel imaginaire
politique et à construire
c'est la condition de l'union nationale
encore fraîche mais une chose ne change
pas la production ces images d'actualité
qui sont diffusés dans les cinémas et
qui sont encadrés par le pouvoir comme
sous l'occupation fait des jeunes
organisé par le secours national et
réunissant plus de 200 villes enfants
dans les différents cirques stades et
cinémas parisiens
[Musique]
le 1er mai ce jour symbolique pour le
mouvement ouvrier avait alors été
travestie par vichy la fête du travail
devenu fait de jeunesse était une des
pièces de la propagande au service de la
révolution nationale
cette révolution conservatrice centré
sur le travail la famille et la patrie
avait été souhaitée par une partie des
français
même avant la guerre ces français est
effrayée par une autre révolution celle
prolétarienne et marxiste qui avait
éclaté en russie quelques décennies
auparavant
l'occupation à lettres pour ces français
conservateur l'occasion là aussi de
redéfinir ce que devait être la france
on en gardera le muguet qui sur ordre de
pétain viendra remplacer l'églantine
rouge que se ferait jusque là les
travailleurs en garde les dates on
change le récit autre récit celui que
l'exposition le juif et la france donne
de la guerre et de la défaite et qui
semble également directement dictées par
le pouvoir
ces graphiques et tableaux ces
statistiques donnent véritablement le
vertige offrant bien la france victime
de sa générosité et de sa traditionnelle
hospitalité
surtout depuis 1936 c'était en juillet
tous les postes des commandes de la
maison france se trouvait entre les
mains des juifs après avoir été dans la
guerre à un peuple profondément attaché
à la paix ils ont conduit la 11 vers la
plus totale
histoire elle fut l'oeuvre destructive
des juifs en france
si certains français résiste à la
propagande fusil à la main d'autres ont
choisi d'orchestrés depuis londres un
travail de contre-propagande radio
londres abrite alors la voix de celles
et ceux qui ont choisi la france libre
et parmi eux pierre dac un chansonnier
qui s'emploie à force de parodie a
raillé le pouvoir vichyste et celui des
occupants comme dans cette chanson où il
tourne en ridicule les soldats allemands
qui recule sur le front est mis en
difficulté par l'armée rouge un jour
adolf hitler promenant sur le denier
perdre a dit je vais vous montrer que
j'ai dû plaire j'ai compris tout à coup
que la défense avant tout devait être
monté sur caoutchouc pour motiver les
troupes
il est important de dire et de répéter
que l'ennemi est faible qu'il recule
qu'il tremble fait village aux éclairs
de 15 pas en arrière durant la guerre de
on peut lire dans les journaux français
que les balles allemandes ne tue pas que
leurs revenus sont en toc
chaque victoire est glorifié et chaque
défaite devient un recul tactique ça
aussi c'est de la propagande de la
propagande de guerre les alliés ne se
prive pas d'en user à leur tour
notamment pour nous offrir leur récit de
la bataille de normandie
partout les soldats alliés sont reçus
comme des amis par les français qui ont
conscience d'être toujours resté dans la
guerre malgré vichy et l'armistice
les français font tout ce qu'ils peuvent
pour aider la vente alliés
[Musique]
l'offensive n'a jamais été facile il
ennemi n'a pu utiliser tout de suite
c'est pour se laver
il possède tout de même plus d'un quart
de millions d'hommes dans le cotentin
quelques jours après les premiers
débarquement les alliés avaient déjà
fait dix mille prisonniers dont les
qualités combattantes de la vie des
vétérans de la vie démarre mais ne
saurait se comparer à celle des soldats
de fromelles en libye de dures batailles
devront encore être livrés mais l'armée
allemande se bat depuis plus de quatre
ans elle a été terriblement affaibli par
la succession des défaites de russie du
gros des alliés par contre les produits
utilisés sont des compresses
l'enjeu est double il s'agit ici de
repeindre la france collaborationniste
en france résistante mais également
d'encourager les français à se rallier à
leurs libérateurs et donc à combattre
ses troupes nazies fatigué et
incompétente
le reportage mentionne les dix mille
soldats d'ores et déjà capturé
mais ce qu'il ne dit pas c'est qu'il
reste encore ray que dans le cotentin
près de 250000 allemands qui eux n'ont
pas abandonné
autant dire que la faiblesse des troupes
d'hitler n'est pas encore tout à fait
évidente pour gagner une guerre il faut
d'abord gagner les coeurs et ça le
général de gaulle l'a très bien compris
lors de la seconde guerre mondiale
l'europe occidentale qui dominait le
monde est en pièces son prestige est
amoindrie tandis que celui de l'urss est
des états unis n'a jamais été aussi
éclatant la france a perdu cette image
de puissance invincible qui lui avait
permis de dominer les peuples d'afrique
de l'ouest et du nord
tout l'enjeu de la résistance après que
les américains rentrer en guerre et que
la victoire devient possible c'est de
reconstruire de redonner une cohésion
pas seulement à la france mais aussi à
son empire
[Musique]
à notre infanterie coloniale et à
novembre où comment marins et aux
aviateurs d'angleterre et comme aux
soldats des états unis cette savante
mise en scène notre avant tout des
foules blanches issues de
l'administration coloniale les
acclamations
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en novembre 1940 les allemands faisaient
à battre à reims le monument au sénégal
étant des pour la france
et bien si l'allemagne avait gagné la
guerre il aurait fallu abattre aussi un
vide devant le monument aux morts de la
côte d'ivoire parce que pour l'allemagne
raffy les noirs n'ont pas droit aux
honneurs des guerriers dont l' empire
colonial français c'est la citoyenneté
qu'on leur refuse mais le pouvoir
colonial promet tout de même que l'homme
africain sera désormais une
préoccupation de l'an pire un empire qui
jusque là se soucier davantage de
l'économie et des ressources
c'est ce que le général de gaulle
appellera le nouveau chemin
ce récit tiendra bon quelques années
encore puis quatre à la guerre
d'indochine
la révolte de madagascar et la guerre
d'algérie et s'en sera fini de l' empire
et de ces belles histoires
[Musique]
après la france républicaine et colonial
de la troisième république
après la france antisémite et
conservatrice de michée après la france
victorieuse de la résistance dans
laquelle nos grands-parents vécurent il
faut trouver d'autres récits manipuler
d'autres images trouver d'autres mots
pour définir qui est la france
ce qu'est la france il faudra bien
trouver un sens à la guerre comme à la
paix il faudra bien remplir ses pages
blanches que ne cesse d'ouvrir
l'histoire les remplir avec des mots
comme on le fait encore aujourd'hui avec
des images et des mots car les mots ont
un pouvoir mais que c'est le pouvoir qui
choisit les mots c'est fini j'espère que
cet épisode vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
nous laisser un petit commentaire pour
nous dire ce que vous en avez pensé
et n'hésitez pas non plus à vous abonner
pour ne pas louper les prochains
programmes
salut fis